boo boo boo you suck okay all right so
um something came up this Sunday where I
absolutely have to attend and I can't do
the 12 hour livestream this Sunday that
doesn't mean it's not gonna happen it
doesn't mean that at all it's actually
kind of helpful in a way because every
time I get in one of these moods where I
want to do something I kind of rush into
it and I get way ahead of myself so
we're rescheduling the 12-hour live
stream to next Sunday next Sunday's when
it's gonna be so that will give me time
and here's why it's good to actually
schedule the event with child's play so
that it gets up on their calendar
because I've never done that before I've
always gone oh yeah I gotta do this and
you can donate right away but if you
schedule an event on South plays website
then I think it'll just net me more
viewers and help raise more money for
the cost so sorry about that really
really thought I was gonna be free this
Sunday so sorry everyone
boo boo you suck but yeah so uh sorry
about that anyway we will be doing it we
will be doing it next week hopefully
this is actually hopefully this gives
you guys more time because I I really do
get overeager for about some of these
things that I just go get in the mood
where I got to do it and I got to do it
now so next weekend
next Sunday from 10 a.m. to 10 p.m. or
plus or minus an hour Eastern Standard
Time we are doing another 12 or not
another but the 12 hour livestream next
Sunday 10:00 to 10:00 thank you so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video bye